so i gotta take him you know that
there's no i have no choice
in the matter
a grand master would just uh
forfeit here
but i'm not i'm not that i'm not that i
like that because i'm a higher level i
like well i like the i like the pitch of
that yeah he's like a grand master would
just forfeit here no i'm just i'm gonna
have to give you the bishop of the night
well don't do what you're gonna do but
don't forget we we talked about fisher
and spassky and i started the game in
the famous fisher
opening that
you know
it was good at one time yeah and it's
like it's i'm trying to bring it back
the opening or what yeah i'm trying to
like i really i'm a fan of bobby fischer
i know they say he went crazy
and all the stuff like that but
like i said his his analogy that chess
is a draw
it's something profound in that and i'm
just like i'm going to try to represent
bobby fischer
a little bit
you're the bobby fischer in this all
right
see that
now will everybody agree
yeah
but that was beautiful
you